the following content is provided under
a creative commons license
your support will help mit
opencourseware continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of mit courses
visit mit open courseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today i want to talk with you about
uh how it is that we can do
research of a scientific kind for
something as complex as human behavior
uh you know as opposed to things that
you measure out in space or test tubes
or under microscopes uh people are are
complex organisms right and to do
research on them to understand human
nature how the mind works how the brain
supports it is a challenging story so
the usual thing is an experiment you
have a group of participants and we'll
talk about that but in the reading for
today and i know first first time we've
done this so you may not have read it
but if you have that be great is it kind
of another thread of the kind of uh of
way that people are studied which is
dramatic individual stories
case studies single stories that are
illustrative of something that we think
are broader principles and a lot of our
biggest discoveries and we'll come to
that later in the course have been made
on very unusual single individuals who
turn out to have a lesson that's pretty
broad uh for for example for the
organization the human brain
so in the oliver saxbook uh there's a
story about donald and um
what did donald do that got him in big
trouble
yeah he murdered his girlfriend while he
was on pcp uh he's in a psychiatric
hospital um
they try hypnosis to help him remember
it he says he doesn't remember it many
of you may know that an astounding
number of criminals under uh under
interrogation tell you they don't
remember anything about the episode
involved right it's uh so people are
suspicious at first for many reasons
because the easiest thing to say is i
don't remember what happened and then
you can't catch yourself in a lie or any
complexity right because you don't
remember what happened and sometimes you
don't remember and sometimes you do but
in this case they try hypnosis that
doesn't help he's in there there for
four years
and then
he knows
conceptually that he murdered his
girlfriend and he says i'm not fit for
society he knows it's a terrible thing
he did but it's kind of like an
intellectual knowledge right it's not a
feeling it's not a memory
and then um um
he has uh he goes biking and something
happens
which is
he gets hit by a car
um and uh so there's what appears to be
a drug induced amnesia of the original
murderous episode he gets hit by a car
he has a severe head injury he's in a
coma for two weeks his left-sided
weakness as he comes out of it which
means the biggest injury was in the
right side of his brain
weakness and numbness and he has frontal
lobe contusions he has injury and
bleeding around with frontal lobes the
cortex that sits in the front of the
brain
but now a remarkable thing happens it's
as if two
you know two insults two wrongs made a
right
the first wrong being the pcp the second
wrong being the accident and now what
happens
he remembers in vivid and flora detailed
the horror that he actually committed
this murder this is of two insults to
the brain one drug induced one a focal
injury uh
repressed the memory and then
unrepressed the memory and one of the
first things i have to do is discover
whether he really has his memory or he
just thinks he has this memory and how
do they figure out
to their satisfaction whether it's a
really recovered memory
or a fabrication of his mind
right that's really important he
remembers details of the murder that are
not publicly available uh that were not
in the information that was given to him
that's a really huge issue in these
kinds of memories so there's a really
recovered memory not a inadvertently
fabricated memory uh and they discover
he has a deep seizure uh activity in his
limbic structures the parts of his brain
uh that are involved in emotion
are having uh seizures so in epilepsy
neurons are firing for no good reason
and that's part of his disorder they
give him medications to help with that
uh but here's
the question for you for a moment to
think about and it's now such a common
question because our society is moving
that way that it's on many tv shows i
see it like every couple of weeks
there's a law and order episode that has
something like this which is uh the more
you know about the biology that
underlies uh that really criminal
terrible behavior
should that be a cause for understanding
it
or or not okay so in this case he took
the drugs he killed the person you think
he's pretty responsible uh but how about
somebody who kills somebody and it turns
out in such a case a man with no history
a grown man with no history of criminal
activity of any kind uh shoved his wife
out of a high window to her death
in the course of a standard argument
right
then they discovered that he has a big
tumor growing
in the basal part of his frontal cortex
now is the man responsible for what he
did
it's a really interesting question right
uh and the more we understand about the
neuroscience of our brains what makes us
do things which lets us control impulses
what makes us murderous there's a guy
kent keel university of mexico is
driving around in a big van with an mri
scanner and he goes from penitentiary to
penitentiary and he images the brains of
serial murderers of psychopathic
murderers okay and he's getting things
that are pretty systematically different
about their brains
and the question is you know what does
that mean does that mean those people
were prone to do it for reasons of their
early environment or genes or some
incident that happened if that's the
case do you forgive them differently
should we have a more different moral
code
or legal code as we discover the brain
bases for some of these things or is
that irrelevant what counts as the
action
so this is kind of thing you could think
about maybe discuss in your section some
the more we understand about the human
brain the more we'll understand about
behaviors that we find terrible
and what does that mean about legal and
moral decisions about how to punish
those or think about those
so that's coming in your lifetime
because there's steady progress on this
and understand how to think about that
is a really big question
so
i'm going to talk with you today about
uh research in psychology and a funny
thing about psychology and i'll come
back to this is everybody is an amateur
psychologist they have to be if you deal
with people you're an amateur
psychologist moreover we live in a world
with oprah winfrey and dr phil right so
in case you're only an amateur one you
hear all kinds of stuff newspaper
internet magazines everywhere you go
friends will tell you stuff about
psychologists who found this or
psychologists have found that right so
you have your own intuitions to deal
with people in everyday life uh and um
here's a kind of a sentence from time
magazine you know that uh you know
drives psychologists crazy if you take
it seriously so here's here's this
literal sentence
almost half of children of divorces
enter adulthood as worried
underachieving self-deprecating and
sometimes angry young men and women okay
so that sounds kind of like a
psychological study of some kind kind of
right
you know uh somebody who wants to argue
about the importance of divorce
and breakdown of the family this is the
kind of thing so let's think about this
for a moment almost half of children of
divorce enter adulthood as worried
are you guys worried about global
warming
a little are you worried about uh peace
in the middle east and how that
influences the middle east and the u.s a
little are you worried of an economy
that may not have jobs waiting for you a
little okay who's not worried a little a
little bit of the time
so almost so it doesn't even tell you
what the half of children in the world
for example are who uh come from
families without divorce right
because that's the only relevant
question it's not are people worried
about stuff
under achieving compared to what how
would you prove somebody's
underachieving
scientifically okay i mean we've
most of you probably have had days where
you've underachieved and days where
you've achieved pretty well but how
would you measure and prove that
self-deprecating well sometimes we think
it's actually kind of nice if a person's
modest okay what's the difference
between modest and self-deprecation and
i like this one sometimes angry young
men and women right i mean
i mean you know i mean it's
are you sometimes angry about something
or another okay
and if you are does that tell us that
society is breaking down and your
parents did something bad that you're
sometimes i mean who as a human being is
not sometimes angry so here's a kind of
psychology sounding sentence on a
serious topic which is you know what is
divorce consequences of divorces and
families and you know should we be
thinking about things that encourage uh
uh marriages to stay stable and things
like that
uh but there's really no information at
all
right uh so from a from a research or
science perspective so i'm going to talk
about a little bit just reminding you
what science is we're at a university
obviously that thinks about science and
does science all the time
remind you of what an experiment is a
very brief history of psychology
experimentation and then walk you
through a few experiments that i find
kind of interesting um
and then some topics related to
psychology so let me start with this how
do you know what is true
how do you know what is true
that you take to be true
what is the answer it was looking like
how do i know please tell me okay uh
well when people try to analyze this and
you can think about it for your own self
one of them is authority
parents teachers textbooks scientists
professors and courses we tell you this
is the truth right and if you remember
the truth correctly you get an a
uh so you know authority is a huge
source i mean right it would be costly
to go around and kind of have your own
idea about everything 12 inches in a
foot i'm not taking that piece of
information without skeptic right i mean
you'd have to you couldn't lead your
life without kind of believing a lot of
stuff but you know you don't want to
believe everything right just because
you hear it repetition or tenacity you
hear something often enough
and people tend to believe stuff
a priori what's reasonable you think
thinks through just by thought what's
possible rational and so on and you know
then maybe a fourth brand of knowledge
to something scientific analysis where
we have hypotheses and we test them in
some version of experiments or or at
least correlations among data
now there's another view
which is kind of uh
that
whatever we think makes something
science is what the scientific community
decides as a community is true right
roughly speaking that is if the mainstay
of faculty in places like mit and
stanford and harvard and so on and
around the world that universities tell
you this is you know how science works
you go okay that's how science works and
i remember some years ago there was a
there was a a lot of excitement about a
uh a a satirical article written by a
scientist where he said oh this is all
just societal authority scientists tell
you what's true just because they
believe in it just like you know
sportswriter says the celtics are the
best
you don't really think that the sports
writer knows scientifically the celtics
are the best right okay uh so uh you
know so and he wrote a paper saying that
gravity is simply a consensus among
scientists uh and a particular view
they're foisting on society okay uh but
none of us would want to really go up
there and jump out the window going well
gravity is you know one person's opinion
and now here's my opinion right okay so
so but it's kind of interesting because
you know uh for those of you who go to
medical school for example you learn
lots of procedures and so on that the
medical community believes is true where
there's not much scientific evidence
behind it but they have to use it every
day
so you know you're used to hearing about
the scientific method it applies to
psychology
in many ways just like it applies to
chemistry physics or biology
we have to test things that are
falsifiable
we have to deal with probabilities of
outcomes in terms of statistics in some
sense
the kinds of data we can have are
descriptive or correlative or
experimental i'll talk about those in a
moment
we are always trying to disprove the
null hypothesis statistically as you
know which we can't prove that something
is true but we can prove that it's not
true
and then finally
like all fields of science the most
exciting today's most exciting
breakthroughs are tomorrow's uh things
that have to be apologized for and
rediscovered right okay i mean what
makes something breaking science is not
that it's known with certainty with no
uncertainty is what's in your textbook
kind of
what makes something breaking science is
it moves the field forward so what's the
difference between the cutting edge and
the bleeding edge is a very close call
so here's a cartoon that says uh it's
he's constantly proving his experiments
wrong okay and the guy's kind of glum
looking over he's proving the null
hypothesis to be correct uh now that's
sort of funny uh for scientists uh but
it's a uh it's sort of funny in the
sense that no we don't really go around
going i hope
you know with all my heart for this
research project i've worked on for the
last five years that it will prove the
null hypothesis there's no difference
between things i'm studying uh in fact
scientists like all humans have agendas
and hopes and like everybody else
so they observe hypothesize experiment
this is data it doesn't always go
perfectly right
and the last thing i want to say is i'm
going to emphasize today
a scientific approach to the human mind
and behavior but of course there's many
other paths of knowledge for important
things in our life religion philosophy
arts and so on there's many things that
science cannot address and i don't want
to pretend that it does you know that's
not a problem too much when you think
about chemistry it's kind of an
interesting problem when you think about
psychology because when we think about
happiness or values or things like that
those topics cut across psychology and
things like religion philosophy and
topics like that
so what makes something an experiment is
you have to have sort of two things
conceptually especially the dependent
variable what you measure the outcome
and the independent variable what you
vary once you have those things in an
experiment you're kind of an experiment
in a broad sense
so in psychology it took a long time it
was until the 1800s that people had kind
of an approach
to doing experiments in psychology and
figuring out for example how to use the
simple measurement of time
to measure how long a mental operation
lasts in your mind so that's pretty cool
if you were to come to a fifth grader
and say how would you measure not a you
know a a a brick or a stone but how long
a thought takes
uh you'd say well that'd be pretty hard
but it turns out it's not as hard uh in
a simple way so wilhelm wants uh who big
figure in psychology first textbook in
psychology first laboratory in
psychology did the following test of
mental chronometry simply measuring how
long it takes you to do things so he
would wait he would show you a light and
you'd simply press the button and that
would take about 20 a fifth of a second
and then he would say instead let's you
do this if the light turns on in this
red you push one button and if it's
green you push another so his idea was
the motor system to push the button is
about the same the time to observe the
light is about the same but the
difference between these two is how long
it takes to make a choice
how long it takes to make a choice
and that difference when he subtracts
them took about a tenth of a second by
that measurement so all of a sudden you
can start to measure in an objective
sense uh how long
a mental operation takes in your mind
uh then psychology went a lot of
different directions a famous one from
titchener who worked with wendt
developed a psychology department
cornell was introspection look inside
yourself and think very carefully when
you think about a topic how do i think
about it uh that lost
its way as a scientific method trouble
is you know one person thinks one way
and one person thinks another way and
you can't really settle it right
so it's a pr introspection about your
thoughts as a private process it's not a
public measure that you can exchange
among scientists like time or
measurements
but we still introspect a lot when we
think about psychology whether it feels
right to us what are the questions to
ask there's still just being human you
can't help but introspect about
psychology topics
in the u.s there was a sort of a huge
response
to to introspection as being too loose
too loosey-goosey one famous name and
this is john watson he said the mind is
unobservable so we can only study
behavior things that people do
actions they take their mouth moves
their hand buttons presses and then we
identify what in the environment
influences those behaviors
the principles of the mind should be
similar between animals and humans and
that the only thing a responsible
experimental scientist can do is relate
environmental factors
to actions
and so there's a stimulus and you can
control the stimulus as a scientist
there's a response you measure the
response and that's your psychology
experiment
and then um
the 1980s became the cognitive
revolution partly this path led to not
after a while to not very interesting
science that was the biggest problem
and people said no we can make
inferences about the mind as it
translates what it hears or sees into
what a person does
so
ideas of representations or knowledge in
the mind or in the brain later on and
how that translates what's out there and
how you act upon it
so
um
i'll remind you a couple more things
then we'll get to specifics so
correlations are uh you can only get in
an experiment right we have an
independent variable uh sorry
correlations you can look at all the
time
experiments only experiments allows us
to infer causation
so let's let's pick an example that when
i read struck me as slightly relevant
so age of parent and risk for disease in
a child
so you're most of you are young enough
that you're not too worried about this
yet and you have no reason to be but for
those of us who are my generation and
some generations back many people are
postponing childbirth
as they do their careers and complete
different tasks and they're getting
older and parents are getting older no
they're they only seem old they are old
okay so uh
it's true it's the case statistically uh
that the older the the mother is uh the
higher the risk of down syndrome so the
statistics are for mothers age 20 20-24
it's very rare
to have down syndrome and the number
goes up dramatically if the mother is
aged over age 42.
so this is simply observation and
measurement but it's something a lot of
women giving birth in their 30s and 40s
are thinking about and worrying about
and it's a it's a thing on their mind
up until relatively recently uh men said
oh it's too bad for those women but
we're no problem for us here right so
you're the yeah you have the movie star
right who's 90 years old and marries a
20 year old actress right you know that
kind of model that you see all the time
then use
because it doesn't matter how old a guy
is well it turns out you know it does
matter
and here's some data for that
so here's the probability of developing
schizophrenia
a disease that's only typically
diagnosed in a person's late adolescence
or 20s
depending on the age of the father and
you can see the father is less than 25
it's one out of 141
if the father is in this 50s it becomes
1 out of 50 a dramatic growth in the
likelihood of an offspring child having
schizophrenia depending on the age of
the father
okay so
now
there's a correlation between age and uh
whether a child expresses schizophrenia
so let's guess about
the possible causes of that i can tell
you it's unknown but let's even begin to
guess about it
let me ask you to guess about it
yeah yeah bad sperm right okay uh it's
not for some reason in some way and
sperm that leads more likely to be risk
for schizophrenia so that's a good
that's that's your first intuition and
that may turn out to be right
problematic something problematic about
the sperm from the male um
here's another one though and this shows
you you know
you know the challenges with
correlational research on something even
so important is this which is how about
alternative which is
who marries later in life
okay
you know you know maybe the desirable
men are plucked off the market on
average in large statistics by age 30 or
something and a bunch of us and i'm a
late marrier you know limp to find some
woman around the world who will accept
us okay and finally out of pity some
woman says okay you drag yourself into
your 50s and i'll i'll take you uh
you know so
right because it's not random probably
and this is we're averaging over many
people but it's not random probably who
marries a 25 in a given society and who
marriage is a 50. it's not random
it could be big differences among okay
and how could we tell that difference
maybe it's nothing to do with the sperm
maybe it's something to do with the
something about the genes and
environment that goes with marrying you
know being a parent in your 50s versus
being a parent in your 20s completely
different explanations someday maybe
we'll know but we don't know now all
right so this is the limits of
correlations and you know it could be
both could be true neither could be a
third story altogether
so that was about me
my my becoming a parent uh late in life
and marrying late in life let's talk
about you all right so let's talk about
the level of stress you have and how
empathetic you are on average your
college generation relative to one's
five or 10 or 20 years ago
so let's ask that question why would
people want to know such a thing
well you might want to understand you
know what what pressures are we putting
uh young people under as they go through
grade school and high school and college
you know what's what's the world like is
it pretty much the same is it pretty
much changing
you know
now how would we figure that how would
we begin to measure that
it's a very simple question
are you more stressed than people 10
years ago at mit
on average across the country
and now you're more or less empathetic
towards other people
how might one answer that kind of a
question
that would be a very interesting path
it's a tough research path but you're
right if we had some biological
signature of stress that would be a good
one but let's let's ask this question
let's say i measured everybody in here
and got your average stress hormone or
something like that now what's my answer
about whether 10 years ago
people were more or less stressed
that would be an outcome yeah that would
be sadly an extreme outcome of stress of
a kind but there's a lot of things are
going okay so so we have to worry about
two things one thing we know one thing
we know is let me ask you another one
you could you could compare
your level of stress
to people who are 10 years older than
you or 20 years older than you what do
you think about that
no
yeah
uh yeah
um be more accurate if you measure you
know if you want to know for a college
student specifically you have to give a
baseline of yourself
from somewhere like before
yeah because maybe people at 20 or maybe
people who are 30 or 40 are more
stressed for other reasons because they
have more bills and mortgages to pay or
less trust for other reasons or whatever
right maybe that's not about the
generation you're in maybe it's about
being a person with more
responsibilities at 40 right okay so
here's for some things you get some luck
and um
you have it in your hand so here's uh
an emotional health questionnaire where
students across the country for the last
25 years have been given the identical
questionnaire it's a questionnaire it's
not a biology measure about their
self-reported measure of stress okay and
this was on the new york times just a
few weeks ago
it's you guys on average across the
country u.s college students are an
all-time high level of self-reported
stress
sorry about that
yeah
yeah so so now it's not the perfect
measurement in every way but it's the
same questionnaire to college students
year and year out by self-report people
say i feel more stressed you can also
see that there's a difference
between men and women women on average
report on average report feeling more
stressed
and it may be relevant and on average
for example there's a higher rate of
depression among women than men
there's a much higher rate of autism
among men than women so it's not it's
not a it's
you know being one sex or the other is
not a gift certificate of uh avoiding uh
mental health challenges but uh you know
these so you're more stressed than ever
okay good luck
we'll try to the best we can in this
course to not worry about way worse but
you know that's something to think about
i you know i got a call the other day
from somebody who said
there's a lot of curiosity about whether
the shift from book learning and book
reading to internet worlds and twitter
and facebook worlds are fundamentally
changing how people think
and that sounds kind of possible okay
and there are people who give amazingly
entertaining lectures about these things
uh
scientifically it's unbelievably hard to
imagine how we would ever answer that so
when i get occasional phone call like
you know what what do neuroscientists
know about that what could they know
about it you know is that an even an
answerable question
if i take you now and say well you've
probably done more facebook than a 50
year old and compare you to a 50 year
old on some other thing is that going to
answer the question of how you think
about ideas given the world you live in
versus the world a 50 year old lived in
no
so there's just a lot of huge deep
things about changes in the world that
we can't even begin to get at sometimes
we get lucky and people been giving some
particular measures for some time
empathy
uh
by self reports and now you if this you
don't i wouldn't fill it out now but you
can take a look just to get a feeling at
your leisure this is a questionnaire
they used
for self-reported empathy it's
self-report
uh
40 lower today than 20 years ago
yeah so on average you guys literally in
college on average by these measures are
more stressed and less empathetic
towards others okay and those two sorry
okay so and those things this is not an
individual this is an average right so
to at the center the levels that society
operates things are going on and moving
for some reason um by the way i can tell
you that when i'm stressed i have less
room to be empathetic okay so maybe
these things are related if you're
feeling stressed your first thought is
not how can i help others but like how
can i just get through the day okay so
uh these these things might be related
so let's turn a little bit to
experimentation
so
and some of the challenges of relating
psychology to real world policies that
are meant to make the world better or
safer in some way
so there's a famous broken window theory
from the political scientist james
wilson the criminologist george killing
and their idea was this
that especially in neighborhoods that
are not immaculately kept
or were to say the other way where
there's a lot of damage around you
things like broken windows is the phrase
they used
that this promotes and people who live
in that community or work around that
community a sense that you know the
rules don't count anybody can do
anything
and then it fosters the growth of petty
crimes
and once you do a petty crime you're
more vulnerable or willing to do a major
crime a slippery slope okay
and in fact
uh
there
rudy giuliani and commissioner bill
bratton employed this they asked the
police to write lots of tickets and make
lots of sort of minor arrests for things
where people weren't upkeeping the
environment or whether they were
littering or things like that
and this is a huge debate because in a
police department you can only do so
much
so if they put if they have a person
working on jaywalking and littering
that's a person not working on you know
major uh crime rings okay so they make
it to try to make a choice where they
think they can make communities safer in
the most effective way and the crimes
went way down in new york in most cities
now
you don't hear crime discussed as a big
topic nationally in some local areas
like in boston some specific areas you
do you know i i don't think in the state
of the union there was a word about
crime that i can remember a week ago
okay it's not a big national topic in
some local places it is a big topic but
not nationally so you don't know
some years ago when people said new york
city was a horrible place to go because
there was so much crime that you'd walk
out from your airplane and get mugged
before you made it to your taxi no it
was you know uh it was like the whole
country was saying big cities were just
crime
you know crime ridden and dangerous they
do this policy things get better right
somebody said that sounds pretty good
but of course it's not an experiment
it's a real life policy and then people
had these kind of you know incredibly
clever reinterpretations of why crime
went down
so the the most you know the most the
wildest one was was in freakonomics was
discussed in that uh which said well
abortion was legalized in
1973 that gave women who didn't have
access to legal abortions
the ability to uh
have them that children on average in
these communities that at least access
to safe and legal abortions would be
poor unstable
addiction-ridden communities
statistically
and that so that if you imagine the
reduced abortion rate in poor areas
could when you count out the number of
of possible criminals in those areas
account for the reduction in crime all
by itself a completely different
interpretation that has nothing to do
with the policy it just said we're going
to have a demographic shift
which will have a weird unexpected
consequence of lowering the crime rate
because it's the finding that
young men in particular are most likely
to engage in violent criminal activity
it's not a
all rule but a statistical average
or
there was a big crackademic that crack
academic that reduced or lots of states
put in laws that put people into jail
for much higher longer periods much more
severe penalties
with new drug laws so it's very hard to
know if the policy that was initiated
really worked or whether completely
other things were happening
that moved the crime rates and here's
some very you know sort of perverse or
or or other explanations
so that left the question is
is broken windows even a good idea just
because
a harvard and we know harvard is always
right but just because a harvard
psychologist says pretty interestingly
that sounds right to me is that even a
right idea okay so let's take a step
back can we test that experimentally so
here's the experiment
and the idea is again that when people
observe that others violate a social
norm or legitimate rule are they more
likely to violate if you see people
around you breaking rules are you more
likely to do it
uh and you could say it seems like it is
but let's let's do the science so here's
an independent measure i'll show you the
environment the dependent measure is in
the number of people who perform a
violation now you can't go getting
people murdering each other and stuff
for an experiment but you can do this
you can have two conditions in the top
condition do you ever go back to your
car or bike usually these cars i think
and they put leaflets in your car and
now what are you going to do you're
running away the leaflet on your
windshield wiper
so they they put it out and they either
had a wall like this which was clean
there's a sign that says no graffiti and
they put on those white pieces of paper
onto the bikes or they put a lot of
graffiti on the wall okay
and people came out from their classes
they went in the glasses they parked
their bike they ran into glass they came
out and they got all these white
leaflets and what they did is watched
and they said how many people put the
leaflet away and how many people
crumpled it up and threw it right on the
ground okay
so you we don't know what they're going
to do with the leaflets they put it away
but we could hope they're going to throw
it out one thing we know for sure if you
crumple it up and throw it in the ground
it's littering and not a good social
norm and sure enough
uh a third of the people littered
uh if the wall had no graffiti but it
more than doubled if the wall had
graffiti so that's a small thing that's
not a broken down complicated
neighborhood but just at that moment as
you roar out of class you get that piece
of paper on your bike and you see like
wow this is a pretty crummy place people
are breaking the rules all the time
twice as likely to throw a piece of
paper on the ground so that shows that
people very easily are influenced by
very mild perceptions of whether people
are following rules or not and will be
their better selves or their worst
selves depending on that sense of you
know are all rules on or all rules off
and there's a pretty good bet they're
not thinking about it right they're
nothing they're saying they're okay
here's uh you know here's littering you
know
not as bad as killing somebody all right
here's the wall well it's 30 graffiti i
mean nobody does that they have an
emotion quick response but the the
environment makes a difference in that
regard
so an important thing about um
studies are this so let me tell you
about this one here's a study that to
look at a drug that was supposed to
lower mortality from coronary artery
disease those who took the drug 80 or
more because people follow whether you
take the drug if you don't take the drug
of course the drug won't work i had a 15
mortality rate within five years
those who took the drug less than 80
percent had a 25 mortality so you'd say
well 10 better chance of living for five
years that's worth it right um
the nice thing is they had a placebo and
there was no difference whatsoever
between those who took the active drug
and those who took the placebo
the differences between was those who
followed the instructions to take the
pill
and those who didn't
so what does that mean how do you
interpret that
it's not the drug
it could be that it could be the stress
uh it could be that it wouldn't
let me make a guess there's no
scientific answer to this
people who tend not to follow
instructions are they mostly stressed by
not following instructions
no they mostly the intuition is they're
blowing it off they're like yeah that's
the instructions but i got things to do
in places to go
but you could be right um so anyway the
idea is what you pick up is are people
who try to take care of themselves they
have a they have a health condition
and the people who are following the
pill instruction
are probably
also doing the best they can in terms of
exercise diet all the things they could
do to maximize their health right okay
and they're taking their placebo or
they're taking the drug they don't know
right but they're doing everything they
can and the people who blowing off stuff
they're the ones who are doing all the
things that aren't healthy including not
even taking your pills i mean if you
don't even take your pills right i mean
exercises work diet is work popping a
pill that's been handed to you uh that
you're told might help you is probably
not that much work so you know that's a
it's what's called self-selection bias
that you stand out if you tend to take
care of yourself or not um
okay
so when we run experiments at
universities
that involve people a huge issue for us
is the idea is this that we randomly
recruit people and we'll come back to
this in a moment then we randomly assign
them to one condition or another for
example the placebo condition or the
drug condition we randomly assign them
to the messy wall or the clean wall
we discover something and then we try to
generalize it as far as we can to people
as a whole we've discovered something
fundamental about how humans work
generalizable principles of human mind
behavior
so what really happens in the world and
you know it's always you're in between
sort of the best possible world in the
world we actually live in um so is it
really who really is it really random
who participates in research studies
in psychology departments where a lot of
the research gets done is it really
random
no okay
so who volunteers have any of you
volunteered to be subject to an
experiment anywhere yeah
okay so
but it's not random you know it's not
some people who they they either need to
make a few bucks or they're very curious
about psychology or they have a friend
who's in psychology or you know it's not
random and in fact
population wide people have just said
that psychology could be described as
weird research for the following reason
that the vast majority of the findings
you'll read about everywhere including
in your textbook but everywhere
are from nations that are westernized
educated industrialized and relatively
rich
democracies okay
the vast majority are between 17 and 25
their undergraduates are graduate
students who participate in research uh
it's been estimated if you're a u.s
college student you're 4 000 times more
likely to show up in a scientifically
reported experiment than if you're a a
person anywhere else on the planet okay
4 000 times because why
because it's changing a little bit but
for many many years you know the huge
amount of research happened in the us at
universities pretty much at better
universities pretty much at highly
selected students all right so that's
and then we never publish that we never
say mit students did the following
things people say at mit students you
know because then we got a different
report from stanford or from umass or
from michigan or texas we say no humans
did an experiment and humans are like
this okay so uh
and that could make us you know it's
just something to think about as you see
studies and stuff like that and people
are more and more sensitized to that as
the more and more of the world uh gets
somewhat uh uh
industrializes uh there's more and more
research around the world but still the
vast majority of findings are you guys
okay um
now that's just to start with who's in
the subject pool or the participant pool
how normal are you when you do an
experiment
are you like yourself or are you doing
weird stuff and people use this idea
that you're really weird when you do an
experiment in another sense because
you're like you don't know what's going
on you're following instructions you
know so they do experiments to show how
ridiculously people behave
when they're doing experiment like they
would never do it so they ask them to
come in and they say would you fill out
200 sheets of paper filled with random
digits add them pairwise and just i'll
come back in a few hours now if a friend
asked you to do that
add random digits for a couple hours you
was like no thank you
i've got about 8 million better things
to do than that right i could multiply
random digits to start with her so uh
but people will do it for hours because
in this weird like i mean you know
that's the instruction and that's what
my mission is or even more ridiculous
they pick up a card after each page
they've added all these numbers you know
for no good reason and the instruction
tells them when you've done the page
tear the page up into 32 pieces and
here's the next page okay in the next
page it's obviously fruitless and
pointless ridiculously so but because
you're in an experiment and somebody
told you to do that right you just keep
barreling forward so you know how much
are we are who we are when we do
experiments versus people following
weird instructions and we'll come back
to that in some serious contexts
that's the subjects how about
experimenters experimenters are never
objective we try to be a scientist as
objective as we can we're never you know
we believe certain hypotheses we have
certain goals we recognize results that
would be super exciting we recognize
results that would be boring okay
we're we're humans too we want to do
stuff that matters we want to do stuff
that people reward us for i mean it's
just human so
here's here's a lowest case example of
how once you're an experimenter you
produce your own results and believe me
it's much more when your result matters
for things like
your career advancement or your status
in the field so students were told that
rats were either maize bright or maize
doll they were told these rats were bred
to be smart learners or not so smart the
rats were all just random rats okay it's
a fake story to undergraduates
then they had them on a test on a maze
and they said in for your laboratory
exercise write down how quickly the the
rat runs the maze okay
and amazingly the the the smart rats did
way better than the doll rats okay now
these are not students trying to become
famous or have a career they're handing
in an assignment okay
and how did that happen
well they went back and it wasn't that
anybody faked it or anything like that
but when they looked at films or discuss
stuff with kids
students in the course
every little thing that the students did
uh that moved the data in little tiny
tiny ways always favored finding the
maze bright rats being brilliant maze
runners so for example you know they
would put the rat if you've ever run
around in a maze does anybody run a
retina maze yeah is it easy
if you pick them up and put them in the
maze that's when they're more automated
now is it physically easy iraq's like
please i'm show me the starting line i'm
ready to go no what are they like help
me out here for you guys who've done
this
are they kind of squirting are they kind
of really act
and they don't like to be handled that
much really no even ones
they're fighting and these are
undergraduates who hardly ever touched a
rat okay they're like please don't
attack me or something so they're
holding it up like and the rats fighting
back and because it's really
uncomfortable that's really unhappy and
the students like really yeah
you know so what happens is
and then they plunk the rat down and
they go oh my gosh it's facing the wrong
direction and it's a smart one wait
let's start start stop the clock let's
get him you know but if it's a dull one
facing the wrong direction it's okay
it's a dull one let the maze so lots of
little things are you sure you wrote
this down was it 12 seconds or 11 i
guess it was 11 oh because it's a smart
one okay so completely innocently
completely innocently as far as we
understand they made the result to
match up with what the expectation was
and it's not just that and if you know
this example you know cognitive
psychologists have studied a phenomenon
like this so try this at your desk each
card is a letter on one side and a
number on the other side
your job is to figure out what's the
smallest number of cards you have to
pick up
to discover if this rule is right
if a card has a vowel on one side and it
has an even number on the other side so
think about this for a moment if a card
has a vowel on one side then it has to
have an even number on the other side
what's the smallest number of cards you
can pick up to test that hypothesis
so here's what people have found
the correct answer is e and seven
uh and about ten percent of people on
average come up with that
many many more people see pick e alone
or e and 6.
why
well everybody gets that you have to
look at e
because it's an even number right so you
flip e over and if that one turns out to
have it's a vowel if it has an odd
number that the rule the hypothesis is
wrong right that's everybody gets you
should check e
pretty much everybody gets that uh j is
irrelevant because it's a consonant
okay now comes the interesting six and
seven
uh because it's because the sentence is
talking about a vowel and an even number
sometimes people feel like got to check
the even number
right but it doesn't say anything about
even numbers couldn't go with con
consonants it doesn't even it doesn't
tell you anything that's not that's not
part of the hypothesis
so you don't you but you but if you
flipped over
number seven and you discovered a
vowel
you'd violate the rule
so what happens is they're tempted to go
for things that feel like they confirm
the question and it feels like e
confirms it and it feels like six
confirms it right and
it's what's called confirmatory bias
that when you look at stuff if you see
what you think confirms it
then you tend to go for that even when
there's evidence in front of you that
could contradict your expectation
okay
so now i'm going to give you a practical
date uh
uh a practical suggestion for how to win
somebody over if you have a brewing
romantic interest in that person all
right all right so finally we get
practical right everything was like you
know i'm not running rats you know i'm
not taking
all right all right uh and i think it's
very interesting because because i think
you know when we think about how people
make decisions in their lives we tend to
think intuitively about big decisions
you know like what's my career going to
be where do i go to college we think
those are the big decisions but a huge
amount of life is little decisions
moment to moment if somebody asks you
for something do you say yes or no
somebody walks up to you at a party do
they they want to talk with you do you
feel like talking or not feel like
talking you know maybe you talk with
them as a lifetime friend a romantic
partner or whatever so a little i think
we make constantly little decisions that
turn out to have big effects in our
lives so here's some evidence about
things like that
that influence that and this is uh work
done at yale
so we describe people as warm
or we can define them as cold or aloof
right
and we could think those words are kind
of arbitrary and most of us if you met
somebody at a party would you rather
hang out with somebody who's warm or
cold
warm okay okay all right just the second
that we're okay uh now
sometimes um uh uh there's an idea of
embodied cognition and here's what it is
we can't really know uh how warm or cold
that person is or even that's even an
abstract idea
but we know we're comfortable when we're
kind of warm and we know we're not
comfortable physically inside us when
we're kind of cold
so there's an idea that when we think
about other people's feelings other
people's thoughts or abstract things in
the world we base them on physical
experiences that we have inside okay
there's a more direct link between
what we know inside us and we use that
to interpret the world out there
embodied continuously your body is the
vehicle for understanding things out
there so here's here's the experiment
it's really clever um there's two
temperature conditions
so what happens is you go into a
building and the
examiner an undergraduate usually or
graduate student meets the subject in
the lobby and she's carrying or he's
carrying a cup of coffee sometimes it's
hot coffee sometimes it's cold coffee
um a clipboard two textbooks okay so you
can imagine it's a setup right person's
walking they're juggling with the coffee
the textbook all the clipboard
and he says on the elevator says could
you just hold my cup while i write down
your name on my list of subjects in the
experiment okay it's very innocent right
on the elevator and so you hold a cup of
coffee which
half the people get a hot cup half the
people get a cold cup
then you read a description of a person
it's just a paragraph and you have to
rate whether you find the person
described as warm or cold and if you had
the warm cup of coffee you're more
likely to describe that person as a warm
kind of a person okay now these subjects
have no idea they held a cup of coffee
they probably didn't even think whether
it was warm or cold
but something in their body that got
warmed up to the least degree possible
right
that thought is still in their head so
when they read a description something
god this seems like a warm person or if
it was a cold cup of coffee
they say oh this seems like a cold aloof
kind of person as far as i can tell
right that little bit of difference so
here's the lesson just so you got it if
you want to take somebody uh because you
have a possible friendship or romantic
interest in that person are you better
off going out for a warm cup of coffee
or giving them a cold glass of beer
but for that first impression
scientific research shows
it's a something warm uh will work
it's not that powerful you're not gonna
be able to control the world okay
but you know what what it says is when
we're ambiguous situations ambiguous
situations we first meet somebody we
don't really know them little things can
start us off on one path or can start us
off on another breath surprisingly
little things um
now then they have to worry about a
confound can you imagine a count found
here think of the rats who knows if the
cop is cold or hot besides the person
holding it
the examiner right okay now maybe the
examiner doesn't try to do this but
maybe the examiner no matter what says
oh we're in the warm condition and i'm
smiling and this is going to be nice i'm
helping this person feel good you know
and here's the aloof condition i'm
giving it and we're all going to be
miserable yeah an examiner knows it
because they know if they have a hot or
cold cup of coffee so maybe the person's
not vibing to the coffee they're vibing
to the expression or feeling or
sentiment of the examiner right who
understands what's going on so they do
one more experiment where they give you
have you seen these hot and icy
therapeutic packs that you can make hot
or cold okay now somebody else makes it
hot or cold the experimenter has no idea
whether it was hot or cold so it's what
we call double blind the person doesn't
know it's relevant the experimenter they
rate the pad and now this is this moves
a little bit they either get after this
thing is over they're told it's a
product evaluation of the pad but they
either got a hot pad or a cold pad
and they could either choose to uh one
of two rewards a snap a beverage or a
dollar gift certificate whichever you
like better okay you want two little
things you could do but here's the big
decision do you get it for yourself
where we can send it for you to a friend
we can send them the snap or their
certificate
if the people got a cold pad
75 percent of the times they say please
give it to me right now i'll take it
if they had a warm pad uh 46 of the you
know the majority of the time they
actually send it to their friend
that pad difference
moved you know quite substantially the
likelihood that you take it for yourself
or you give it away quite substantially
right if you're a charity trying to get
people to donate or you want to get help
from somebody a 75 you know 25
success rate is a lot worse than a
54 room right it's a doubling a doubling
of whether you keep it for yourself or
you're generous to your friend just that
cup of coffee or whether it's just that
that therapeutic pad
i'm going to do two more and then go
differently how about money
when you think about money i don't mean
traumatic things about money just a
little bit about money how does it
influence how you relate to other people
okay here's the experiment
uh the idea is that money on average
when you just think a little bit about
it and i'll show you how ridiculously
little they think about it uh
they think that their hypothesis that
money makes you think about
self-reliance you earn your money or
your bank account you know
uh compared to situations where you're
not thinking about money
so here's here's what they did they had
people come in in three conditions they
either and they had to unscramble
sentences you have no idea what's going
on right you got a sentence like cold it
desk outside is
which you would make into a good
sentence
or high a salary desk paying okay so you
just make those you scramble those words
around but the money condition has a
word like salary in it
or
you get the neutral sentences that have
no money reference and you see monopoly
money in the corner of the room okay so
we're not talking like people just sent
you your tuition bill okay or whatever
or or you just found out you know that
you're uh you're you're that something
terrible happened financially or you won
the lottery it's monopoly money okay
it's just like the idea of money in them
all right okay uh
and then they give you a task to do an
experimenter as he or she leaves the
room they say it's a pretty hard task
you may want some help so just come and
get me i'm glad to help you not a
problem
so what happens here's the probability
of getting help
and it's incredibly more for the control
groups i got that did the sentences
without money and way less not only for
the people who unscrambled the sentence
with the word salary but also way less
if they saw monopoly money in the corner
the mere idea of money not money given
to you not financial trauma or financial
gain the mere idea of money
makes you less willing to get up and get
help
so the positive it makes you more
self-reliant the negative is
people were less willing to help
somebody say now the end is the examiner
comes in and says you know i'm an
undergraduate like you i've got huge
pressure to get this paper in can you
help me code can you help me score up a
few sheets okay
uh people were twice as much willing to
help
if they just did the neutral things than
if they scroun unscrambled the money
sentences or saw the monopoly money in
the corner of the room because just that
thought about money goes like man okay
self-reliance we're all in it for
ourselves okay
i've got my money you've got your money
you know good luck you know we're all
we're all we're all out you know okay
self-reliance can be a good thing
but it doesn't necessarily go with
helping people very much also yeah
i agree with you maybe that's why they
also had the one where you just get the
scrambled sentences
okay i agree with you these are all you
know you could think there's many many
ways to think about this um okay the
last example this kind of want to show
you is
dating behavior
uh
and the way again an experiment can
challenge various ideas so uh and this
is specifically about dating between men
and women the story uh to the extent
it's been studied would be a little bit
different if you're dating with intersex
so
for dating between men and women who is
more selective in their dating choices
do you think
who's more willing to date widely or a
lot
or less you know
what's your thought if you have to
generalize about
men and women on average in your
no okay
okay so uh an evolutionary psychologist
and i love evolutionary psychology but
it drives me crazy too okay evolutionary
psychologists welcome well because you
know by evolutionary theory men have to
go and make as many offspring as they
can to keep their genes going women have
to be more selective it takes nine
months to bear a baby it takes nine
seconds uh to do the male part right
okay
estimated uh
okay so uh
so you know so this might or might not
be true it's kind of fun we all laugh
about i always find it kind of amusing
to sort of think about you know
so but uh
how would we actually know
if this is vaguely true on average
how would we actually know
if men for dating behavior are more how
would we even on is that true is that is
that a you know bad myth that bad rap or
whatever yeah
yeah thank you very much so there's an
entire uh uh research enterprise out
there now that uses online dating sites
which of course it's only in the last 20
years or something you know that they've
existed i think so it wasn't before and
the other one that's been a treasure
trove of data a speed dating
environments okay where you can observe
things and measure things and those
studies have shown for example that
online dating on average men are one and
a half times more likely to send email
offerings you know dates to a woman than
the other way around compared to women
and in speed dating to um uh men are
more likely to indicate there would be
happy to date a person they met than
women so
there's objective evidence that this is
true on average in this society at this
time
um
and so everybody's oh yeah this shows
the evolutionary psychology now
evolutionary psychologists are crazy
because on the one hand it's certainly
the case that our minds and brains
evolved
through evolution okay so there's
something about the history we went
through as a species that matters for
who we are now that's got to be the case
on the other hand it was a different
world before internet dating and speed
dating right i mean it's hard to know
how those things line up exactly so
here's the fun thing it turns out that
on average in speed dating uh a typical
speed dating an event will have like
four minutes right so you typically have
women sitting at desks is it almost
always set it up that way and the men
are sitting in chairs in front of the
desk and they meet and they talk for
four minutes the bell rings the men jump
up and they shift over one station right
and then what happens is for each time
you meet a person you fill out a card
that says yes or no i'd be willing to
have a date with the person and if you
have two yeses from the man and the
woman
the speed dating organizer
exchanges the information so they can
make direct contact is that what sounds
okay all right and
men make more yes responses and it turns
out this doesn't have to be this way but
almost from my reading that almost every
speed dating thing has the men rotating
around
okay and the women sitting there waiting
for the men to rotate around so let's
just ask this question what happens if
the women rotate
which almost never happens but they did
this experimentally they said for half
of the speed dating sessions
the men will be sitting at the table and
the women will stand up and move a chair
over every four minutes the bell rings
so the women are moving and rotating
and here's the here's the results
uh basically what's showing on the left
are when the men rotate the standard
condition uh the first one it's romantic
desire men feel more romantic desire on
average for the partner they sit with
they feel that more chemistry is
happening
with the person they sit with and the on
the bottom left corner
they
also um
are more likely to give a yes response i
would like a date with this person okay
but reverse the roles have the women
rotating and look at these bars there's
no difference at all
you completely wipe out the male female
difference in self-reported romantic
desire per person self-reported
chemistry they think is happening and
the yes no responses that i would have
it you completely eliminate it when the
women are rotating
it's flat even
so
what do you that's that's the result
what do you what does it suggest
what happened to the evolutionary
psychology
it disappeared just by having the women
rotate around the room it suggests and
we don't know this with certainty but
that people are following this up who
are interested in this it suggests that
there's something about getting up and
approaching that person your body going
here i come okay i'm i'm not sitting in
my chair hanging out you know it's like
we're you know here i come
that makes a person energized feel more
romantic feel more chemistry is
happening and more likely to ask on a
date and it doesn't matter whether
you're a man or a woman at all
okay it's the getting up and that
physical approach just you're more
invested you're more out there who knows
what it is completely eliminates what
everybody had said is an ancient
inevitable evolutionary difference
between men and women and this isn't to
say there might not be some of those
streaks in us who knows
but speed dating is not showing that
okay all you got to do is have the women
rotate and you completely eliminate
what's thought to be some hardwired
biological difference on this dimension
now talking about that when we do
experiments like this that look at
sort of fun
fun things like dating around a
thing or age the difference between a
five-year-old and a 20-year-old or year
20-year-old an 80 year old cultures
there's lots of experiments to compare
say western cultures versus
eastern asian cultures we'll talk about
that later in the course in terms of
behaviors genes whether you have one
gene or another
all those things
are those independent variables
no
we can't assign you randomly to be a man
or a woman
young or old
to come from the united states or japan
or china or to have this gene or that
gene
it's not that we couldn't do stuff
you know it's a monstrous world but but
not ethically and it's never going to
happen right so
so whenever you have science that talks
about differences between men and women
or young and old or cultures or genes
it's not really a completely independent
manipulation we can't assign you
randomly and so it means everything in
the world about what it means to be a
man or a woman a 20 year old or an 80
year old come from this continent or
that continent have this gene or that
gene those are not things we can freely
manipulate and you have to be extra
cautious in interpreting those kinds of
studies because we can't randomly assign
you to condition we just can't
okay and we i didn't talk about um
the fact that we up until this moment we
made every conclusion a complete
generality about human nature and people
are different one from the other
individual differences we'll talk about
that later in the course too
so for the last couple of minutes i want
to talk about this folk psychology and
you know everybody is ideas by
psychology so if you have this piece of
paper if you would zoom through it
ideas about people in psychology and
just where there is some scientific
evidence
uh if you just zoom down to mark yes or
no
on average do opposites attract
on average is familiar breed contempt on
average more people present in an
emergency are you are you more likely to
get some help
on average are there such things as
visual learners and verbal learners and
if they got the right kind of
instruction that would help them in
school
is hypnosis baloney does subliminal
advertising work you know when things
are presented so you don't see them
below consciousness does it help you buy
something
just playing mozart uh to an infant
boost their intelligence mozart effect
is old age on average associated with
dissatisfaction if you're unsure of your
answer when taking a test i'm going to
tell you the science about this it's
best to stick with your first hunch
practically every website tells you that
have you heard that many times
okay i'm going to tell you what the
actual evidence is about that and how
they get that in a moment
uh ulcers are caused primarily by stress
a positive attitude can stave off cancer
raising children similarly leads to
similarities in their adult
personalities you know
low self-esteem is a major cause of
psychological problems people's
responses and the ink block tests tell
us a lot about the personalities
interviews help identify those most
likely to succeed in medical school
okay
i'll give you a minute
okay
we'll come a bunch of these will come
back to the course the answer for all
these is this and there's evidence to it
all so let me i'm going to tell you
about four of them for
for 10 minutes okay
one of the ones you might want to know
most about is the uh changing your
initial hunch answer okay how do you
know that so that people have gone back
over test scores and look where people
crossed out an answer or erased an
answer that's the best source of
evidence they have in large samples and
people are twice as likely to give a
better the correct answer than to move
to a wrong answer
that's the empirical evidence okay
so so it's a fantastically interesting
disconnect
uh that you see so many places and
teachers advise you go with your first
hunch when you're unsure the empirical
evidence is you're much more likely to
be correct when you go with your best
final answer okay all right i mean of
course you're get you're not sure so
you're going to miss a fair bit but
you're twice as likely to come out with
the correct answer when you go with your
best possible answer uh so that people
who crossed out their answers or erase
their answers they were twice as likely
to move to a good answer then leave
behind
a good answer yeah
you know
you picked an answer
yeah that's an excellent question we
don't know they could have gone like
five times back and forth
the assumption has been on average uh
that you know people will go once back
and forth but you're right
but but ask yourself the other question
too what's the evidence ever that going
with your hunches and nobody's been able
to show that okay so where there's
evidence it's all in favor of best
answer
and nobody's shown evidence that hunch
is the best way to go empirically
that doesn't mean that sometimes it
doesn't happen but on average that's the
way that it ends but your question your
point's excellent okay so i how about
rorschach tests every psychology program
clinical psychologist in the country is
required to learn how to administer and
evaluate abortion you know this so this
obviously shows
obviously it shows some sort of horrible
sex act between animals and
all right
no it's a yeah you know these kinds of
tests you're supposed to read it and
then the examiner listens to you and
they figure out something right okay you
know there's been about 10 000
publications about this there's no
evidence that there's anything uh
predictive or correct about this test
none zero none okay people argue it
people give it you know people have to
learn how to give this test uh so this
is a disconnect that happens a lot
between clinical stuff and experimental
work i mean those you know researchers
don't can't grasp why people still give
this
medical school interviews those of you
who will apply to medical school
will
get interviews you get interviews for
jobs you can interviews for all kinds of
things in your life what's the evidence
that interviews are any good for
anything
how could you know
whether interviews are good for anything
a company interviews you a university
interviews you
how would you even decide whether so i
can tell you that social psychologists
have shown repeatedly that interviews
are cesspools
for discrimination because people tend
to like people who are like them okay
you know oh you went to mit you know
yeah course nine yeah
you know then you go oh man this is
going to be good right right or i went
to caltech we didn't like mit people we
thought they were a little bit snobby or
something like oh that's not going to be
so good or okay so uh so you know social
psychologists have shown if you just
vary information and practice interviews
uh people tend to people tend to like
people who are like them by background
by appearance and so on on average they
try not to they try to be fair but okay
so we know that but how about me okay so
here's what yell here's what they did
yale compared students who were accepted
or rejecting the basis of an interview
so they were all had scores that got
them to the interview
and then then they looked at them where
they went in pairs or larger than pairs
to other medical schools so let's say
you got accepted by yale and you were
accepted or rejected on the interview
but you ended up as two students at penn
or two students at michigan okay
you're sitting next to each other
right one of you was accepted by
interview at yale one of whom was not
who does better at that other place
they're dead even the interview added
nothing for predicting grade point
average or completion of medical school
here's one more example university of
texas uh enlarged in the midst of their
um houston in the midst of their
interviews it enlarged
from 150 to 200 students they had
interviewed 800
the 550 who came were among their top
ones they interviewed them they liked
them that came
and then they had and all of a sudden
because the state legislature said
by law men they need to take 50 more
they took 50 more who didn't do so well
in the interview
okay
uh those 50 more performed identically
to the ones who got in with a successful
interview they couldn't find a
difference between them now there's at
least one thing you might think
the interview might have done
but we don't know but that's but people
what do you think it might have done so
the outcome was your grades in medical
school and your likelihood of completing
medical school what else could an
interview have been relevant for
maybe maybe maybe
something about bedside manner or how
you relate to people maybe maybe maybe
but there's no evidence that that's true
okay now you're starting to grasp with
straws so there's no evidence that
interview processes make any difference
anywhere but everybody does interviews
all the ways because uh we always think
we're kind of good judges of human
nature or something okay so so
interviews uh it's very hard to tell
that they ever do anything so here's my
last thing self-esteem
you cannot watch you know oprah or dr
phil without some discussion of
self-esteem at some moment
and it sounds good to everybody i mean
nobody would wish for you as a parent or
friend for you to have low self-esteem
and in fact higher self-esteem is
correlated with higher initiative and
persistence happiness and emotional
resilience and also unfortunately with
people who are narcissistic and bullies
okay i mean yeah
i mean yeah on average and how they
measure it just so you know because this
is a problem too like how do you measure
it you have
the there's several scales but the most
widely you scale is this rosenberg scale
so you have that too if you want to try
it out on yourself okay
okay self-report uh and when they
reviewed 15 000 studies some years ago
they could find no evidence that higher
self-esteem leads to better things it
all seemed the other way around that
like doing better at things
led to higher self-esteem okay they
could never find that pushing your
self-esteem up does it having said that
i can tell you as a parent of two young
kids or if you have friends and you care
about them and you know this we like to
praise people to build up their
self-esteem right we tell you you're
awesome you know someday you'll go to
mit i know you will okay you're a
wonderful person and you're smart and
you're beautiful you know parents want
their children and teachers too to grow
up and thrive and build up that
self-esteem so how could and and the
easiest way to do that is praise right
just telling your kid how awesome he or
she is or your younger sibling how
awesome here she is get their
self-esteem up so the last thing i'm
gonna tell you and then we'll be doing
about three minutes is uh we're from
carol dweck that shows you how danger it
is to how to encounter productive it is
to have um
you know praise where you don't think
through its relation to people and
in one sentence we'll talk about are you
going to succeed in life by your effort
or by your talent you know what's a
bigger question than that wherever you
get to in your life it's going to be
based on your effort or your talent or
both i'll just have a sentence about
that now but so here's the experiment
she did with fifth graders she had to
perform a pretty hard task
and afterwards uh randomly they were
either praised for their intelligence so
a person said to them
you fifth grader you are so smart i
can't believe how great you did on that
in february okay
or they were praised for their hard work
this shows a lot of hard work okay
different kid and some kids got no
praise at all
in this experiment okay now then they
get a task that's even a little bit
harder
how does the different kind of praise
influence things and here was the
finding
if you were praised for your
intelligence you did worse on the second
test if you were praised for your hard
work you did better if nobody said
anything your performance didn't change
and the idea is this you understand
praise for your intelligence you did
worse on a hard task praise for your
effort you did better and here's the
idea
that if we praise people for their
intelligence to build up their
self-esteem they start to care more
about how their performance reflects on
them than the performance itself
because if i you're trying to prove that
you're an intelligent person you care
less these people the students who get
that kind of praise for their
intelligence they persist less than a
difficult task they say it's they they
don't enjoy challenges why they just
want to ace everything to keep proving
they're smart
okay
uh the kids who get praised for effort
they're kind of like okay i'm going to
make some mistakes but i'm just going to
keep going because with effort i can do
things sometimes
and it turns out that it makes a
remarkable thing and so we'll come back
to talks about you can view your
intelligence as a trait
i have only so much
or as a growth
the harder i work the smarter i get but
i have to do the hard work to get there
okay and we live in a society that often
goes by
fixed trace american idol
the harder the work the better you sing
or who has the talent is discovered
who has the talent is discovered right
okay right
because the idea is you know you're a
certain amount of musical talent and now
the judges show and you break into the
world and you're a famous singer right
um
so ask yourself this uh
when you are good at what you do is it
because something in your genes and
environment made you good at
or is it because you try really hard
so uh malcolm gladwell has this
statement that's floating around gets a
lot of attention that anybody can become
great at anything if they work on it for
10 000 hours
so how much of your success in the past
currently in the future is going to be
based on your effort
and how much is going to be based on
your talents
and how would we know that and we're
very talent oriented to society
and it seems like the more we encourage
effort maybe the more people might
flourish so we talked about how
psychology and science experiments brief
history of psychology experimentation uh
some issues in experimentation and some
psychological topics and some practical
information for being generous and kind
and winning friends rapidly okay thanks
very much
you